uh
other than a vague feeling
right
yeah yeah and you don't need to make
decisions in your life on anything on
vague feelings and so i would just
encourage both of you to continue the
learning process
and
yeah i would have some real estate in
there if you're willing to pay cash for
it
but if you guys are just now getting out
of debt and you don't have a big pile of
money you're probably not going to be in
the real estate market for a while and
buying real estate on
debt is much riskier than the stock
market is you're asking for it when
you're doing that so we tell people not
to do that i don't do that tyler i would
suggest two things one if you've never
contacted and met with one of our smart
vester pros go to ramseysolutions.com
set up an appointment and maybe set up
two or three so that he can sit with you
in the office of one of our smart vester
pros and let them answer all of his
questions is my new uh the minutia to
the broad that's the first step but i
also tell him to go in there not don't
buy anything yeah this is information
this is a
we're gonna go to class right we're
gonna and you're gonna do this as a
favor to me right then the other thing
is i'm gonna tee dave up really quick
tyler because over the course of
50 60 years what's been the average rate
of return on the stock market a little
over 11 close to 12.
he's got it she's got to speak in super
simple terms almost the ross perot
poster board here's the graph here's
what it's done over a long period of
time simplicity will help
yeah but i mean it's you just learn the
history of something that's right and
then you don't worry about it you know
as much because you're you're then
you're you're
you know facts are your friends fear is
not your friend
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
susan is with us in portland maine hi
susan welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave good afternoon
so i have a rather um uninformed
question so i apologize for my
lack of information but i'm calling
about a lump sum pension
uh distribution
from my husband's employer
he
so the amount of the distribution uh
well we're both 65. i we were both
planning on working for probably another
two years
but
he's been talking with
talking with people in his work who are
retiring this year and who are planning
to retire in 2023
and i have a question about the
withholding
that
the um
the employer is
i believe required to withhold from your
distribution is that correct
well there's two options on that one is
if you actually take the distribution in
cash and bring it home put in your
checking account they are required to
withhold
20
and it will be taxed on
your actual tax rate
which will probably be more than 20
what's the lump sum how much is it
well well the lump sum from the pension
is 475 000.
that's its value right now okay i don't
think it's going to go up a lot okay so
here's what you want to do instead of
that
you want to go to your smartvestor pro
your your investment advisor
and
do a direct
transfer
rollover of the lump sum distribution
into an ira in mutual funds
because you don't need four hundred
thousand dollars in your checking
account right now
and there's no reason for you to pay
there's no reason for you to pay taxes
on it right now and so i would roll it
all to an ira
in mutual funds
that you sit down with your smartvestor
pro and pick and there's no taxes
withheld
and no taxes due
when you do that
and so they're they're telling my
husband that there is a 20
withholding there is if he takes it home
but he's here there is a 20 withholding
and the taxes will be greater than that
because you're you're going to have a
400 000 income that year so you're going
to have a 40 tax 39.2 okay so
um you're gonna get hammered so but they
are not required to do that if you do a
direct transfer rollover they are
required not to touch it
as a matter of fact okay
okay and then there's no withholding the
entire amount goes into it exactly it's
called a direct transfer rollover
meaning it doesn't come home to you
it goes from one type of retirement to
another type of retirement you're just
moving it around all still under the
protection the umbrella of the
retirement plan so that it doesn't get
hammered by the government
okay and then when you of course when
you do take out anything you take out is
gonna be taxed right and you're gonna
have required minimum distributions
beginning at 72.
yeah okay so
on okay and
is there
so i'm sorry another unemployment
question but there is there isn't a
capital gains tax correct there's no
capital gains at all on any of this
in any situation it's all ordinary
income
it's all your regular tax on your what
your income is and basically in the
future that'll be whatever your income
is plus whatever you withdraw from this
in any year is income
right so when you bring some of it home
from this direct transfer rollover later
like if you pull 100 grand out that's
100 grand of income that year
correct
and so but there's no capital gains at
all on it
okay so i already have to have an ira
account established right and and i
don't know you need to go to you need to
go to your smart investor pro or whoever
you guys work with and
and uh you're gonna establish a new one
it has to be a separate new one but it's
an i it's an iu open an ira then they
send the paperwork from that ira from
that mutual fund company over to your
husband's company your husband's company
sends the money directly to them it
doesn't come to you
don't let them write you a chat right
right right i don't want it to come to
me you're right for for the reasons that
that you just stated correct perfect and
um is my is the employer required to do
that is there dude yes they don't have a
choice they can't say no this is
regulation this is tax rex okay and um
you know they may be ignorant they may
be ignorant about it and somebody has to
teach them but um but usually if
somebody's got a big enough pension that
there's 400 grand in it they know enough
of what they're doing that they know you
can do a direct transfer
yeah and is there any benefit then to
like retiring this year and taking that
versus working i mean we were both going
to work another two years so
if he can take the lump sum next year
there's there's no problem the only
thing is that it
when you move this money it doesn't die
when he dies
but a pension dies with him
right oh yes of course so if he if he if
he wants to work into 23 and then dies
before he gets that money out of there
that's a four hundred thousand dollar
error
excuse me if i'm the benefit you're just
telling him don't die
okay all right all right no pressure all
right
and and i mean and we both have 401ks as
well so i guess we'll be facing this
perhaps the same situation exactly
you'll do the exact same thing with your
401k when you leave
okay well i'm i'm relieved thank you so
much and i did i did reach out to um
to the smart vessel pro
people that that your site recommended
so thank you and i and i heard back so i
i was just hoping to be a little bit
informed before before going to them so
thank you so much they'll tell you the
exact same thing and it's a fairly
standard process and that'll keep a big
chunk of taxes out of uh out of
washington dc which anytime we do that i
think that's a character thing yeah we
should have a sound effect like a little
show party sound effect anytime we help
a listener or a viewer avoid taxes to
the government it should be a
celebration there'll be some kind of
confetti digital confetti right boyd is
with us in houston hey boyd what's up
oh not much new
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
uh i had um
my wife passed two years ago and she was
looking after all her money
and i got hit with a tax bill 140 000
so i put a mortgage on my house it was
free then i put a mortgage on my house
to pay them
when she passed
and i've been trying to figure out i got
i have 2.2 million to start with
in my 401k
but i didn't want to make any movements
on it until
you know i got everything because
looking after the money is a hard job
and
now i would have been listening to your
show this is not the time i was just
going to take out uh
enough to pay this all off i would but
now they're saying
is that right yeah i pay off your house
today you got 2 million bucks you got
140 000 mortgage i pay your house off
today
yeah let's drop down to 107 1
700. yeah it'll come back up i'm not
worried about that part i just want you
to be rid of the mortgage how old are
you i'm uh 66. okay okay
are are you confident about what you're
doing with all this stuff how did you
end up with 140 000 tax bill
oh
i worked overseas and i didn't
reach didn't report something oh okay
okay so i had to
either pay them
and i should have paid them up front
yeah oops
yeah okay
so that but that was while she was alive
yes sir she looked after all that okay
i'm so sorry
that's a hard thing to go through and
then it leaves you half knowing what's
going on or not feeling confident anyway
of what's going on but obviously you
guys have done a a wonderful job saving
and investing congratulations on that
part
but the problem is i get all this advice
from people but
majority of them don't have any money
well i don't need advice from people
people are stupid
yeah you don't you don't do that you
need to get with a good investment
brokerage firm like one of our smart
vester pros that has the heart of a
teacher and let them teach you to
increase your confidence
that changes everything doesn't it ken
it really does and and i just want to
encourage you boyd getting with one of
our smart investor pros with the nest
egg that you already have and the advice
that dave has given you you're going to
be absolutely debt free that that
investment and that fund is going to
grow now you're going to have knowledge
of what to do in the future take a deep
breath you're going to be okay and
you're going to be able to get out of
this but go see a smart investor pro or
two or three and pick one that you feel
like you've got a great connection with
and let them teach you you make the
decisions because you're going to be
really clear and that's going to give
you confidence theme for the hour so far
knowledge yeah
displaces fear it's true this place is
lack of confidence it's true clarity
displaces lack of peace knowledge
know what's going on this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
do
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five victors in
atlanta hi victor welcome to the ramsey
show
victor did i push the button i did push
the button victor are you there
all right we're just going to put you on
hole victor and figure out what happened
there chris is in san jose hey chris
what's up
hello how are you all doing thank you
for taking my call better than we
deserve you're welcome how can we help
yes we're in kind of a unique situation
we just recently moved to san jose from
oklahoma and we sold our home there and
we want to follow the baby steps and
listen the show for a little bit um but
we also want to be able to buy a house
someday we have four children
and
we're not sure if we should follow the
baby steps even though i normally know
you would recommend doing that
we have about three to six months
of
reserves but my job is not necessarily
very secure because i'm a pastor
and because it's so expensive here would
put us in a really bad spot if we were
to
use the money that we have in savings to
pay off our two vehicles which we could
pay them both off right now but it would
leave us with no savings
we just bought a new van because we have
a fourth child
so
we're not sure how to proceed we have no
retirement to speak of except for my
wife's retirement who's about to be a
stay-at-home mom as well
um
based on the situation that we have four
children she has about twelve thousand
in her retirement account which what's
your own what's your income pastor
um make seventy five thousand per year
uh but that's before tax i'm considered
um
self-employed but then i also get
another 2200 per month from a va
disability why is it why is it not
stable
well just why did you move your family
from oklahoma city to california to a
not stable situation
i found out more about the finances
after i got here
i was a full-time student before that
going through college or seminary this
is my first job as a pastor i
didn't understand that we didn't have as
much money
in terms of the church
and what we're bringing in and this is
the first time they've ever had two
passers on staff
they already had one on staff
so i was not completely aware
of how it could be we're getting by it's
been a year now and everything's good
this far it's
just i suppose it's unstable in the
sense that
if something went south at all god
forbid something like covet happen again
or whatever it
you know i might be the first one that
gets let go as is my fear there so what
do you owe in your cars
we owe a little less than 11 000
on one vehicle and then the one we just
purchased is we owe 32 000 we just
bought that one you can't afford that
car pastor
okay
you're way overbought on car
that's
i look for about a year bullcrap the
inventory oh crap not buying it
you make 75 000 a year you bought you
got a fourth kid and your mother your
mother your wife told you to go buy a
van and you did
but you weigh over purchase you put your
family in jeopardy with that with that
purchase that purchase was very unwise
and that's me being kind
okay you need to sell it
and you need to get a van that'll haul
your kids
for about 10 000 bucks
and then let's just pay all of that off
and uh then all of a sudden your life is
stable again the destabilizing factor
here is this van that's what's caused
everything to go on tilt
you don't have this van situation you'll
be able to pay off the other one you'll
be able to pay off a cheaper van and
still have money left over and you
wouldn't be freaking out
but the fact that you want to pay off
something that you can't afford
40 000 total 30 and 11
and then leaves you with no money and
when the church is also financially
unstable that's a problem now i don't
know how you're going to go home and
sell that
[Laughter]
yeah it depends on how new it is and
yeah you've got so much tied up in
things that are going down in value no i
mean i don't know how you're going to
sell that to mama oh yeah i agree she's
not going to be happy
with it
yeah who did what yeah yeah well you
guys you guys did an impulse purchase
based on the emotion of a new baby and
moving to a new city that you really
cannot afford
you really really stepped in it
and um you know you got if if i woke up
in your shoes that's exactly what i
would do and then i would pay then i
would pay off
i pay cash for whatever you buy get this
will probably sell for pretty close to
what you paid for it
since you just got it but um you simply
bought something you can't afford when
you have more than half of your annual
income tied up and things that go down
in value it's very difficult to prosper
very difficult and cars and anything
with wheels and motors goes down in
value period
and so this is just a it's
you know
you guys did a lot of them you know you
graduated you from seminary you moved
you took a new job you're in california
you got a new baby there's a lot going
on so i'll cut you some slack but uh but
you got to go back and undo this
decision yeah and i would just you know
challenge you pastor that you know this
with your training you're in ministry
you're gonna have to go home and talk to
your wife about this and this is gonna
have to be vision casting not demands
you're gonna have to she's got a safety
gland and she's got that desire glenn
and she wanted that van and you you got
the new baby and she really loves that
van she's probably never had a van that
nice that's a tough battle to fight but
the way you win that is i would
literally take that car payment and i if
i were gonna do this with stacy i would
write that figure big on a piece of
paper this is what we're paying per
month and then i would just do some
simple math times 12 times 24 times 36
so she can see if we sell this van and
we don't have this car payment anymore
look how much more money we actually
have and really speak to her safety
gland i think that's the best way to do
this
i really do proverbs 22 7 says the
borrower is slave to the lender and sir
you are feeling that yeah
you're feeling trapped and you know you
are
and that that's what did this and so um
sorry but that's exactly what i would do
if i woke up in your shoes and if you
don't do this you have left your family
vulnerable
not the church that doesn't that is that
is in question
not the move
not you being
called to the ministry none of those
things left your family vulnerable a
stinking van did
so let's just call stuff what it is
so that that's what that's what the
danger it's a danger point is what it is
and it without the pressure of that
particular thing
this whole situation changes pretty
dramatically
victor is with it that was victor no it
wasn't
i tried to get victor a minute ago and i
screwed it up or victor screwed it up or
who screwed it up victor you or me
i have no idea
how can we help you but i'll take the
blank that's okay
sometimes i hit the wrong button i've
been doing this a while but i do it
sometimes what's up
hey nothing much um so i'm in the
process of selling my house right now
and um i'm not sure exactly how much i'm
getting back but i was just trying to
see is with the money that i do get back
it might be 30 30 000 might be a little
bit more um because we still own the
house
so um
i was just trying to see what the money
that i get what should i do should i
save it i pay off some of my debt
or where are you going to live
uh i'm actually moving in with my sister
for now
until i figure out a situation uh i
don't think buying a house right now is
the best best idea
so and i don't because of the situation
in your life
uh yeah
okay
yeah all right
so for right now you're just kind of uh
reaching for some safety
yes how much debt do you have sir
so i owe 26 on my car
and
um if i sell the house that would take
the
debt off the house so
26 on my car maybe like 900 credit card
debt
what do you make
uh 55 000 a year
there's a theme here ken yes
yes
yeah uh he just shows that i i hear it
on the top yeah you know what i'm going
to say then what am i going to say
um
the car
the car
sell the car
yeah i would go buy a 10 000 car with
cash and i would sell this
other one
and again you're trying to reach you're
moving you're selling your home you're
moving with your sister because it's a
life situation and you need a sense of
safety right now and just exactly like
the last caller this car is stealing
your safety
this over purchase on a car so
that was the sell the car segment for
those of you just joining us this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality host to
the ken coleman show where we talk about
or he talks about jobs careers
getting
the ability to make money
doing something that you actually like
and uh can actually make a big
difference in he's my co-host today
you've got questions about that jump in
he's right here to help you and of
course we'll talk about whatever you
want to that's what we do here on the
ramsay show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five ken it is worth revisiting
because we just sold two people's
precious cars
um hypothetically if either one of them
do it
um not sure either one of them will by
the way uh but the uh uh
the the the car is the largest thing and
i'm a car person i like cars i'm a
anything with a loud muffler i'm a good
redneck and so um
you know i i
i get it
um but cars go down in value they're the
largest purchase
that we as consumers make that goes down
in value
and consequently the arithmetic tells us
that
uh the car payment and today the average
car payment in america is over 700
the car payment is
more of a detriment to your wealth
your ability to become wealthy than just
about anything else that's exactly right
and as you point out all the time you're
putting all that time and effort you
just think about the amount of time you
spend at work
how much of a percentage of your overall
expenses that vehicle is and then remind
yourself it's depreciating in value
and you're going to be upside down in it
before you know it and that's what i
mean george w george and i uh co-hosted
the show a week or so ago and he showed
me this tick tock video we played for
the audience and people admitting with
glee dave that they had a twelve hundred
dollar car payment uh one couple said we
have twenty four hundred dollars in car
payments and they were saying it was a
smile on their face like hey it's just
what you're supposed to do and it's mind
numbing the messaging that goes into
this that you've got to have a brand new
car or a newer car and people are
overspending to your point they cannot
afford it yeah and and it really let me
just tell you what it is okay
it's prestige
exactly right status you're right
because look at my car
and everything else you say about it is
is a justification and a lie completely
but at the end of the day it's prestige
oh yeah because a 32 000 van will haul
four kids and so will a ten thousand
dollar fan
all four kids safely
we're not putting their little lives in
jeopardy right that's a bunch of crap
that's right and it's not you know well
i want something reliable and all those
used cars are reliable you know what
your new car is a year after you got it
it's used yes
and you must be about to break down you
must be about to die right now and by
the way kids destroy a new car as
quickly as they do a used car they don't
care they're going to throw their little
mott's applesauce containers and their
cheetos and goldfish everywhere have you
seen rachel's car you must have been
inside rachel's i haven't but i know
she's got three kids so well she's got
three kids and she's never kept a clean
car in her whole life oh boy but it's
just like uh man she just it looks like
a trash hole and it's like but it's got
it's got the can we see a little bit of
that goldfish are ground into the carpet
you know it's like oh my god but yeah
the the and that it doesn't matter what
you pay for that's what you're going to
have that's my point why buy a brand new
van when the kids are going to destroy
it well it's okay if you've got two
million dollars if you want to go buy a
brand new van i don't know but that
doesn't happen very well but but we're
talking about somebody making 75 am i
making fifty thousand the twenty six
thousand dollar car thirty two thousand
dollar car oh man this is um
you know and all it is is you get car
fever
which you know you which means your your
brain quits working right
and you start you go oh we have to have
something reliable we have to have
something safe and we haven't we have
babies we have to have room for them all
we can't put them in this whole thing
and that's right well that's true that
old thing may need to be changed out for
a different old thing but it's true um
but listen you're just you're
mathematically saying
with that purchase
i intend to stay in the middle class
yes
that's what that is it's a death
sentence yeah to your math yeah you
settle for it well i'm gonna settle for
the life i have to live just so that i
can feel good about myself when i pull
up to soccer practice and my car looks
like everybody else's or maybe a bit
nicer yeah you really nailed it on the
whole status symbol thing well it's even
worse than soccer practice it's the
stoplight
at least you know the people at soccer
practice the people at the stoplight
you'll never meet them and the amount of
money you lost while you're sitting
there at the stoplight to impress
someone you will never meet
is astronomical so true i had a young
guy call on the show one time and talk
about how he was in sales and he needed
the really nice car because it went into
his entire credibility and i said let me
tell you something you realize there's
parking spaces in the back of the lot or
around the corner they don't care what
you're driving you're not driving into
the lobby of their building park around
the back
look sharp use an iron you're gonna be
okay usually brush your teeth take a
bath you don't need a super nice car to
close a deal yeah if you do then you got
the wrong deal yeah it's it's a problem
i you know i've i've done sales most of
my life in one kind or another and i
don't recall ever making or losing a
sale based on what i was driving it's
true
when i said when i first moved to
nashville years ago and i was in sales i
was driving a ford tourist day that had
no air conditioning and the the carpet
or whatever you'd call the fabric on the
roof headliner what do you hey thank you
dave i just said carpet the car it
probably did have carpet there's as far
as carpet if there's a taurus you have a
shag carpet on the roof but the top of
the thing one day david started drooping
yeah and and
stacy and i were newly married we've
been married two years and i literally
had a staple gun that i bought recently
for household duty and i fell in love
with the staple gun
jeremy breeland one of our leaders here
saw this i got out of the car one day
was irritating me was it coming down i'm
a short guy and i got home and i went
and grabbed my stable gun in the garage
and went and went
three staples it was fantastic until i
gave it away to a a 16 year old girl in
our church that needed a car but i drove
it for three more years with staples in
the headline yeah i've done that too get
over it nobody cared it was a great
story actually yeah and you need those
stories to be able to tell your kids
someday yeah
stephen is with us in cincinnati hey
steven welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so i have a question about giving um i'm
20 years old and i'm on baby step 3b
and i have some close friends of mine
who just recently
lost their baby
that they were carrying and i really
felt led to give them a gift of fifteen
hundred dollars
and i know that they're not that good
with money and they're they're pretty
normal when it comes to debt and being
in debt
and so
i really feel led to give this to them
but i also kind of want to plant the
seed and find a way to get them on board
with your baby steps and maybe give them
my copy of the total money makeover
but i don't know how to do it
like in a way that's not
hey you're fat here's a diet book and i
was just wondering what your intense
advice would be
you're a great guy that's awesome you're
great man i love you that's awesome
that's very good
cool beans um
you know i the thing i learned to do
years ago is i don't have to talk about
them i'll just talk about me
and i don't mean that in a self-centered
kind of way my point is this you don't
need to tell them things about them that
you have observed just talk about you
and just say hey you know there was a
point in my life i was really struggling
with money and i had done a bunch of
stupid stuff and there was a lot of
stress in our lives in our life and our
marriage and my and all i did is worry
about money all the time and uh when i
finally got control of it it changed
everything
and uh this book the stuff in this book
is exactly how i did it and i don't know
if you guys need any of that or not if
that if it matters to you or not but i
got to tell you this book meant the
stuff in this book meant a lot to me
and so i wanted to give it to you as a
gift
i have a follow-up
i've been following your program and
your baby steps since i was a freshman
in high school so
i can't really come from an angle where
i've made big mistakes with money which
is a good thing but
i was like about the household you grew
up in
oh yeah lots of i learned just blame it
on your parents
and just say you know when i was growing
up mom and dad were doing this stuff and
so
i couldn't stand the idea of handling
money the stress i saw in our household
when i was a kid and so i started doing
this stuff a long time ago like when i
was in high school this is the stuff i
did and it's kept me from having to have
the stress
same angle but you're the point is
you're talking about your story
not their story
and you know that's not offensive then
if someone gives me a book and they say
hey you know i lost a whole bunch of
weight doing this and um
you know and and i feel so much better
and i've got a lot more energy and this
is the plan i used and hey i don't know
if it means anything to you but i want
to share it with you then you can hand
it to me i may read it i may throw it
away
but i'm not insulted you didn't call me
fat
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show we're dead is dumb cash is
king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today on ken's show he
talks about careers and talks about the
idea of getting a job getting a you know
actually getting employed number one but
then doing it in such a way that that
you're working for people you love and
love working with and making actual
money doing something you care about it
matters a lot it changes the whole
formula doesn't it can it really does if
you think about our relationships and
then our work those are the two most
important things to us as humans and
sadly so many people still think that
work is just something that we have to
put up with i'm just gonna deal with it
i'm gonna deal with uh crappy leadership
or toxic co-workers or just being bored
doing something because it's a good
check because it's the only thing i can
do and we slog through a week
just feeling like well i'm duty-bound
and not realizing that there's a unique
contribution you can make where you get
paid really well
and you enjoy your work and it's
possible and you know listen
getting out of debt
many times is the greatest step to
stepping into that dream job because now
you have no limitations and so this all
works together not to mention as you've
said many times um your your income is
your greatest wealth building tool so we
want to help people
when it works so they're winning in life
open phones you can talk about that or
whatever you want to this is the ramsay
show the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five josiah is with us in new
hampshire hey josiah what's up
hey ken and dave how are you both better
than we deserve sir how can we help
glad to hear it i'm 25 years old married
and um
debt free in baby step four
and applying for
term life insurance so i'm going through
xander and got
approved for 500 000 but i'm wondering
whether i should go with a 20 or a
30-year term
my thought being if we're debt-free now
in 20 years i'll be 45 will i have a net
worth high enough
to
not require that insurance or should i
go with the 30 and stay insured until 55
at which place i can be more confident
that would be that we'd be there how's
your health
health is good um smoke no
nope non-smoker are you obese
nope okay
uh i would buy a 20 year
okay now let me tell you how i did that
okay
here's what actually happened with me
knock on wood i've been healthy as a
horse my whole life okay
hardly seen the inside of a hospital
unless i was visiting someone else
so um
what happened was i bought my first term
life insurance when i was your age
and uh i bought a 15-year
level but then what happened was we
added kids we added income
and i wanted to upgrade the insurance
and so i had a choice then of buying yet
a new policy and getting rid of the old
one or just buying additional so like i
bought 500 000 in your case okay later
on i might buy
another 500 000
but that might be three years from now
or five years from now
and as you've noticed it's not very
expensive
doesn't cost much money
and so what's going to end up happening
is you're unless you lose your health
along the way your ability to get
insurance you're going to end up adding
policies or buying whole new policies
and starting the clock over
gotcha so you don't need a 30 you're
going to end up buying a series of
policies or replacing the earlier
policies as you want more and more and
more depending on which way the math
works the best and um
then you're going to be in a position to
begin dropping them later or when you
look up and you're 45 and you go we're
100 self-insured you just cut the cord
on the whole thing and let them let them
float away um and so but what ended up
happening in our case was i've added
policies uh every five years or so from
25 all the way up to 60 not to 60 about
50 something and i kept some policies
even though i didn't need them recently
just swi sharon wants them
and it really didn't have anything to do
i mean it wasn't like she's not she that
like that policy is going to make the
difference when she eats or not that's
kind of silly but even those policies
are starting to expire now and we're
definitely not going to buy them even if
she wants them i'm done with this so um
we have convinced her that she's okay i
think i've got a acronym for that one
what if sharon wants it as swi you just
came up with a new one d
dc dave doesn't care
[Laughter]
ddc
you're not doing it you're done well i
mean it's it's you know she's okay and
she knows she's okay now and that thanks
that's gotten rid of the that need but
what ends up happening is you're not
buying one policy that's gonna serve you
throughout your entire life you end up
adding
incrementally as you go along and so
five years from now if you buy another
20-year policy or another 15-year policy
you just started that clock over on that
portion the other one when it expires
you're probably not going to renew it
you know 20 years from now that's where
i am at you're describing our journey as
we began to have kids three kids you
added as you went along yes added as i
went along obviously we were able to
upgrade in-house over time and so
sitting with our smart investor pro we
determined what that right amount was
and i agree it was like three four years
ago i just did it and so that'll
probably be the last one obviously i
mean we shouldn't need it at all so that
you described exactly the journey that
i'm in and i'm i'm 23 years older than
him now but the way our brains work and
i did the same thing josiah when i was
your age i'm thinking well if i want to
just get a 30 and i'm done it's over but
it really it's it's more life it comes
at you in layers
rather than linearly like well explain
to young folks so so if they're getting
ready to start a family what you
recommend when you go from a couple no
kids to one kid or two how you the whole
time i'm just saying you know 10 to 12
times your income because when you're 25
if he's getting 500 000 then maybe he
makes 50 grand okay if something happens
to him
you know
if she's got 500 000 bucks if she's got
one if she got a baby she's still got
500 000 bucks invest that at 10 percent
in a good mutual fund if it's making 10
it would pay off pay out 50 000 bucks
we've replaced his income without even
touching the principal
and so that's the idea of 10 to 12 times
your income
on on you and guys you got to go to
xander insurance and get a quote if you
haven't done this because the deal is
people are blown away how cheap term
life insurance is
and it's gotten cheaper over the years
oh yeah i mean i bought some one time at
45 and i came back in my 50s to buy more
and even though i was seven or eight
years older it was cheaper yeah because
the rates had come down because they're
using better and better and better
actuarial tables that are more modern
and reflect reflect the uh the health
improvement they were using tables from
the 1940s oh yeah and then they started
using tables from the 1960s and now
they're using tables because life
expectancy has changed yeah and i mean
it's already cheap but if you have the
preferred health designation i don't
know if that's what they call it can
make a lot of money i like to recommend
this to dudes i dropped weight like a
wrestler three years ago when i did it
super disciplined dave and i got the
preferred rate and saved got more oh
here's another still if you smoke oh
yeah it's double oh yeah double yeah
double that's why i asked if he smoked
or he was obese yeah that's right
because it's double all you gotta do is
just quit smoking and it cuts your
insurance in half oh and it saves you on
all the cigarettes i want to save you on
all the health problems and
yeah you and no quarter pounders
within three days of taking your blood
test there's some world-class advice
dave right here on the range that sounds
like that came from experience oh this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is here
he talks about jobs and careers every
day number one best-selling book from
paycheck to purpose he's my co-host have
you ever noticed that when you commit to
change in one area of your life it's
easier to make progress in the other
areas met thousands of people along
their journey to building wealth who
also did other things like lose 50
pounds or find a career that they love
or overcome stress and anxiety what
seems impossible
is possible when you have a smart plan
and a smart plan you turn up the focus
and intensity on your goals and that's
why we're bringing the smart conference
to dallas texas on saturday october 22nd
it is our only live event with tickets
left in the fall here and we'd love to
have you uh the tickets are 35 for
general admission vip and platinum sold
out long ago
and uh there's probably about a thousand
fifteen hundred tickets left to this
it's gonna be about eight thousand folks
and it's all day long it is your top
thought leaders in every space ken
coleman will be speaking
uh from his number one book from
paycheck to purpose how to find and uh
and
get the job that you love making money
like you've never made before it's
awesome rachel cruz will be speaking on
money of course dr john deloney will be
there speaking on mental health and
militant wellness on parenting marriage
boundaries all of that mixed in
george campbell ramsey personality will
be speaking as well uh others i'll be
speaking and on marriage uh craig
groeschel and amy from life church in
oklahoma city so looking forward to
having you guys all with us this is
dallas texas saturday october 22nd
there's not a lot of tickets left if you
want to come out do come out we ran into
a lot of people at phoenix this week who
had uh wanted to get in and couldn't get
in the sold out events there in phoenix
so don't wait until you're one of those
folks ramsey solutions dot com slash
events and get your seats today
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from rachel in tulsa i am currently
doing a survival job and planning to
pursue a career as a ux ui designer i
found a six-month program out of college
for five thousand dollars that would set
me up well for career placement i do not
have anything saved at this point and
wanted to know if it was smart to borrow
the money to complete this program if i
would be able to pay it back quickly the
answer is no
uh it's not okay and you don't need to
borrow let me give you just a really
quick exercise that will open up your
mind here to how achievable this is if
you need five thousand dollars let's
just take 20 hours a week if you can
work 20 hours a week additionally to
what you're doing and you get a job
making 20 an hour that's very doable
that's not a pie in the sky example
okay based on 20 hours a week at 20 an
hour even after taxes you're gonna be
five or six months away from making five
thousand dollars cash
to be able to pay for this now you don't
have any debt
now you're qualified
to get into the field that you want to
get in a field that is very lucrative
you're going to start out doing very
well and have a ladder to make six
figures pretty quickly so you don't need
to borrow the money what you need in
this situation i understand what i'm
saying this is very difficult what you
need is some patience but if you can
take that frustration or that desire to
get into this new field
and channel it into some hustle
and really crazy maniacal focus you can
make that five thousand dollars and i
didn't even mention selling things
cutting your budget but we can get to
that five thousand dollar
nugget if you will quicker than we
realize all right you can drive uber
eats and pizza and make a couple grand a
month yeah pretty easy yeah uh or more
yeah i would make if you work like a
crazy person yeah i just gave a 20 hour
a week i know and you kind of you come
to dumbed it way down but if it was me i
would do it in about two months oh for
sure i'd go get my 5 000 bucks but
here's where you get 5 000 bucks you
earn it you don't borrow it
that's the point that's the point of the
answer and you go do it right now and
you gear up and you go okay i want this
i want it bad and i'm willing to pay a
price for that so i'm giving up my
friday night parties and i'm giving up
my saturday night parties and i'm going
to work
like a crazy person for a short period
of time so i can have the cash pay cash
for this and then go get the job because
let me just tell you these things
there's only one way borrowing money to
do anything works out
is if it works out perfectly
so your your theory here is is you're
going to go get this dude this new
designation and quickly you're going to
make the money back because quickly
you're going to get a new job that pays
more
that may be true but it might not be
true
it's possible that doesn't happen yeah
and uh you're counting on it only the
debt thing only works if it works it
doesn't work when things don't work and
most of the time things don't work
exactly like you think they're going to
and this is not a necessary risk no no
you can do this we're not saying don't
go get the thing we're saying go get it
but go get it fast and go you know just
go crazy i mean walk dogs babysit dogs
babysit kids house sit deliver stuff
sell stuff go crazy work six jobs and
knock five thousand dollars you can get
in two months easy yes
it's no i take that it's not easy
mathematically easy yeah you'll be tired
that's right but tired didn't kill you
you know it you know so that and the
other thing that'll happen is uh when
you go get that degree that way
and you're holding that that designation
in your hand
and then somebody wants to jerk you
around and not pay you in a potential
job you'll walk from that
because you you paid a price to get this
designation yeah and you won't be you
know we're gonna this is gonna pay off
in other words we're gonna force this to
be a payoff situation so good stuff good
good question very good open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five josh is in louisville hi josh how
are you
i'm doing well i got you all better than
we deserve what's up
awesome um yeah so i've got an investing
question for you guys
um my fiance and i just recently got
engaged and are beginning to think about
and kind of plan for
our marriage
i know that you all typically recommend
15
of your income being invested
as it stands right now each of us will
get about a 5 match from our companies
and they do both have a roth option
would you all recommend once we get
married that we
throw five percent into each of our
company's roth and then five percent
into like another raw
or
throw seven and a half percent of each
of our incomes into each of our
companies uh 401k
good question now let me clarify you're
saying you will be debt free when you're
married
correct yeah neither neither of us have
any debt and you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
that's correct yeah and so now we're
starting our 401ks newly or we're
starting our retirement plans newly
married now the way the formula would
work is this what do you make
uh i'll be making about 60. and what
will she make
uh about the same maybe just a little
bit less okay all right so 15
of 120 000
okay that's the number you're trying to
achieve
i don't care where it lands
it doesn't have to land 50 on you 50 on
her let's pretend that your 401k sucks
and hers is awesome
it could land over in hers
okay because you as a married person in
the event of a divorce you're gonna
split up their retirement accounts
regardless of who the name they're in
that's how the law works okay so it
doesn't matter whose name it is in
uh what matters is the the most
effective then how do we parse it out
we use a formula we laughingly call it
rock paper scissors in a way except rock
paper scissors can go different ways
this only goes one way and it is
uh match
beats
roth beats traditional
now what that means is we're going to do
all the match we can do because you're
getting 100 ready to return before you
even get started so you said you got a
five percent match she's got a five
percent match you're gonna both do five
percent there and and and what does that
amount to well it amounts to three
thousand bucks each and so that is uh
six thousand dollars going in to get
both matches of our fifteen
percent
and uh
you know we're trying to get to what 15
18 000 bucks is what we're trying to get
to 15 120 000 okay
now then you're gonna do roth and you're
gonna look at her 401 k your 401 k if
they both have good options you could
probably just finish up there
and it does end up being 50 50 that way
and that's fine but if one of them sucks
just go ahead and get the match and bail
after that put enough in to get the
match and put it all in the other one
and if that doesn't get you to your 18
000
then you'll do individual roth iras and
you'll get there you won't get to
traditional
so always get the match first then do
roths of some kind
then do traditional you've got enough
roth available to you to never get to
the third stage
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
christina is with us hi christina how
are you good thank you how are you
better than i deserve welcome where do
you live we actually live just south of
here in spring hill tennessee oh your
neighbors okay wow big long drive for
you yeah yeah well good to have you
welcome how much debt did you pay off so
we paid off a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars wow and how long did
that take it took just shy of three
years wow good for you and your range of
income during that time well it actually
is a little different from probably what
you're
used to hearing um we had one more
family member and so we started off with
about
117 and now it's one less family member
and i'm making around 55 to 75 because
part is commission ah okay what do you
do for a living i am an insurance agent
oh good for you yes dave ramsey loving
insurance we're not mad at all insurance
agencies we just want you to buy the
good kind yes good for you welcome okay
so um
uh it sounds like there's a story here
uh yeah one less family member what does
all this mean yeah so um
we started out a little while back and i
guess just during covid um
that one less family member started
making some really funky decisions and
it
was a little bit of a break of our
family and unfortunately um that just uh
gave us quite the
the hard time and he went in one
direction legally and we
kept on moving forward ourselves wow
yeah
i'm sorry thank you you've been through
a lot of pain uh yeah and actually it
happened during
my last semester about two years ago
i just got this really strong impression
uh to go back to school and so
right in the midst of my last um
semester getting my bachelor's degree um
this all happened and then i just felt
god saying no no you can keep this is
this is this is it just keep going this
is the plan and you're you're going to
be okay so i finished i graduated in may
and a degree in what uh organizational
leadership good for you yeah and where'd
you graduate from middle tennessee state
university awesome yeah we had a great
program there and debt free too
yeah yeah i bet you did yes yes and so
you unbeknownst to you
uh were getting prepared for this
breakup
yeah had no clue it was very very sudden
um no plans no family arguments nothing
a lot of um
silence and the the cool thing i guess
it's cool and not cool at the same time
is i didn't realize how much of our
journey we were actually i was actually
doing by myself with the kids um and uh
because i had a spouse that was like
sure whatever whatever you want okay
fine yeah that's good so i didn't have
any pushback no fight but i realized
afterwards that i i was i was running it
with my kids alone so
but we did a good job we did a great job
already carrying it so when you had to
carry it it wasn't you didn't notice
as much actually
no that's totally true um god was just
um directing
and it lightened the load a lot yeah
yeah and you've got a couple of kids
yeah times three
so i'm two
four six six kids wow yeah yeah always
wanted a big family and
we we made one and i have no regrets and
they've been amazing they've been on
this journey with us we put up a
kind of a thermometer up on the wall
with really cool chalk and colors and
all that and we just started just
filling it up as we were paying off debt
and they were supportive and my teenage
son was helping babysit while i went to
deliver people's groceries and some of
them helped me to clean offices and just
make everything we could to just pay off
all the rest and it was amazing they
they were literally on this with me it
was amazing
i mean you have walked through hell and
you're joyful and bubbly about it it's
great i mean
your attitude is amazing yeah thank you
i'm quite honestly stunned uh and i
guess the the the the only question
that's popping in my mind right now i'm
rarely speechless uh but the only
question that possible mind is is how
much does the financial piece come into
play
in in the world you're in right now well
i mean had i not been
uh
you know listening to god this whole
time i would have uh
with everything that occurred um i would
have no degree we'd have debt i don't
know what we would be doing but instead
i was prepared to be able to go right
into a great job
one that i love by the way because i
followed a lot of your principles john
and um very very happy and we don't have
any debt no car payment nothing and so i
was able to be able to maneuver us
upward without going into debt because
we needed money we were like oh my gosh
no more paycheck so that was a big deal
huge huge deal what kind of a ladder do
you have financially now in this new
role um
i'm sorry i don't really understand how
much opportunity for you to grow your
income yes oh i'm sorry bladder of
course yeah um a ton actually where i'm
working um i work for a very very
supportive uh
team that thinks very much like i do and
and we're it's amazing but i'm really
good at my job and so they put me in
what's called the aspirin program so you
know give it five ten years and i'll
have my own agency i'm not gonna go into
debt for it obviously you're gonna be
crushing it wow yeah yeah it's gonna be
great but it really all came down to you
know when you said before you know kind
of going through hell i'll tell you um
it really shows you kind of like money
in a way shows you what kind of person
you are yeah um you either sink or swim
you either get negative or you get
positive and you just it's it's
what you feel like doing and i we felt
like surviving and having a nice happy
life and not going downward and not
digging a hole and so we did well let me
tell you you have a spine of iron thank
you ain't no stopping you yeah you're a
force of nature girl thank you i love it
and and you know you're taking the high
road obviously by staying vague and i'll
i'll respect that thank you very much on
all the crap and everything but uh
the good news is you just kept smiling
and kept pushing and kept smiling and
kept pushing and and god has rewarded
that so so proud of you thank you you
have to feel
accomplished you have to feel powerful
yeah it really kind of gave that um when
you say spine of steel on john um it
really did because when you get to that
point
you don't it's it's not a pride thing on
the wrong side of pride but it's more
like oh
i can see now that i really am able to
do this
and um i was just telling somebody when
i was when we were driving over here
you know the kids are listening to you
guys on the radio with other people's
debt-free screams getting them ready and
there's someone talking about credit
cards and i looked over at my son ben
and
i was like hey you know some people
really do use credit cards and i just
thought he would be like oh yeah that's
true mom but he was like oh really
and i was like yeah and he goes
oh i feel sorry for them
but um i will tell you though we really
didn't do it completely alone we had a
ramsey financial coach uh mr david
uh gibbs over here um he has just stuck
with us this entire way he's been with
us almost three years that's great yeah
what a wonderful story we're very very
proud of you thank you
okay what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of that is oh um
working really hard take every single
side job you can
just keep smiling about it tell yourself
this is right and you're strong no
matter what you've got going on and
that's the reason i wanted to do this
today
to
single moms to people who have lived
through crap thing people who think
they've got too many kids they can't do
it whatever it is um that's absolutely
incorrect and i've got three kids who
are special needs and we we pushed
everything everything so
anybody who says they can't that's
absolutely false wow well you just
proved it yeah you just proved it thank
you mike drop wow we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you financial
peace university one year membership and
total money makeover read them give them
away whatever you want to do bring the
six kiddos up on stage let's introduce
them right quick before we run out of
time
so what are their names and ages so just
going from top to bottom this is daniel
and he's 14. benjamin is 12. julia's 11.
joshua's nine rebecca's seven and
elizabeth is five amazing christina and
the team from nashville 170 000 paid off
in three years count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream all right ready guys
three
two
one we're dead free
wow
[Applause]
now and wow a young couple 25 years old
making 160 000 a year and you can't
figure out how to get out of debt uh
shut up
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today when you're worried about
money it's all you can think about and
that stress affects everything your
family everything until one day you look
up you feel like your entire life's on
fire you don't have to live that way you
don't have to when you have a plan for
your money you'll discover peace
even in the middle of the fire
as you walk your way through it and out
of it just like our last debt free
screamer in financial peace university
you'll learn the simple plan that's
helped almost 10 million people
budget
save
invest spend wisely get out of debt
build wealth and increase their
generosity
and now the course includes dr john
deloney george campbell rachel cruz and
me it's the best version of fpu we've
ever done and we're offering at the
lowest price we have ever had to make it
easier
than ever to get started decide today
you're done letting money stress rule
your life get started with financial
peace university visit
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.com
fpu
ken uh
when i was growing up i went to
mom and dad were in the real estate
business and they would take us to sales
conferences
and i got to hear some of the old-time
motivational speakers and later on
became friends with zig ziglar before he
passed away he was the kind of the king
of that
and uh
you know they talk all the time in that
world about your attitude is everything
and you decide your attitude
and um
that last debt free screamer
was
i mean it's intriguing she's inspiring
yeah i mean it was unbelievable it's
intriguing to me though that the same
set of circumstances come at one person
and they choose
and you do choose
to approach it with one attitude or
another i do this i mean i don't i mean
we all i guess everybody sometimes
something comes at you and just go you
have a little pity party and it's like
well there's no fear my life is bad and
it sucks
and we do that and then other times you
just rise up like she did and man i just
want to be her when i grow up all the
time no question she she went into i we
don't know what the story was but oh my
god it was obviously a mess and leaves
her with as a single mom with six kids
yeah and nothing but smiles and on fire
and jamming it and everyone watching and
listening knows she's gonna be okay and
you know what that had to do with not
the circumstances it had to do with her
attitude and how she's approaching it
well our values
drive our attitude i really believe that
we still have to make the choice but
there comes a point when hardship and
the unexpected comes your way and it's
really a fork in the road and so i'm
either going to have a positive attitude
and keep pressing on or i'm going to
have a negative attitude and i'm going
to withdraw i'm going to retreat and
there's an incredible woman who who her
values dictated her actions and see
attitude determines actions and i think
underneath attitude is always what do i
value and here's a lady that said you
know what i got six kids
i there is no option i love these kiddos
we've been on the debt-free journey i'm
not gonna stop it's doable and she
realized i was leading the charge anyway
and so she chose to say you know what
i've still got my six kiddos these these
kids are everything to me god arranged
it to where i finished my degree just as
i needed to create professional
possibilities what's a financial coach
in her life to help her ramsey coach to
help her walk through this stuff but all
these things she did right and she just
looked and said okay this sucks
but there can be a better future i
whispered to her just as we took
pictures with her i said hey the best is
yet to be and she looked at me she goes
i totally know that i mean that is the
attitude you're talking about and she's
been through some storms yeah well and
and you know the truth is everybody gets
a storm oh we all get welcome to life
and the last two or three years have
been a storm for a lot of people
in a lot of situations and
whatever you know whether it's a a
medical diagnosis whether it's a
relational blow up whether it's a career
blow up
a financial mistake
a business error
i mean you know or something comes at
you that you don't have any control over
but the only thing you can control and
this sounds so pollyanna man when i used
to hear these old motivational speakers
i would think yeah bullcrap you know uh
but it you know
there's nothing
that comes at you
that a negative attitude makes better
correct
it doesn't make it go away
to have a positive attitude and a
positive outlook and a way of doing it
but and but she was a stellar example of
i'm going to choose to
embrace this and call it all joy yeah i
can hear zig in my i could hear him in
that classic southern accent that that
kind of evangelist draw he talked about
the attitude of gratitude
and you know she in that moment decided
to focus on what she was grateful for
not what she looked like this is a
message for me and you it's a message
for everybody listening that uh whatever
it is you're facing uh
you know maybe you don't need to look
like you're weaned on a pickle
you know i love that that's true maybe
you don't need to sit around going
life is bad and you know biden's the
president before that trump was the
president and you know you know it's bad
and life is bad and you know a lot of
people spend their whole existence like
that keeps you stuck in the past yeah
well it keeps you stuck period yeah you
don't move out with that one so um but
man and uh it's
so
the lesson for everybody listening and
for me
out of that is i get to decide yeah
i get to decide am i going to smile at
this and go this sucks and we're going
to do it anyway yeah you know or
am i gonna sit on my hands and go well
life is bad and you know there's
systemic problems with the economy and
america's just falling apart it's a
horrible place and i'm proof of that ux
that's great you sound like the guys had
a pickle right there that's pretty good
yeah you know you instead nobody ever
does negative attitudes with a positive
enthusiasm that's the whole point yeah i
mean intonation slows down you know it's
crazy i you know i think we all have to
choose in those moments instead of
becoming discouraged we have to get
determined and i think that's the focus
it's okay all right i'm not gonna let
this overtake me i'm not gonna let it
determine my future and you talk about a
a true hero you you call our audience uh
rightfully so heroes all the time now
how can you not look at her and i love
that she called out other single moms to
say hey
i'm not you can do it i'm up here to say
you can do it yeah i'm here to prove
hold my beer i got you guys
that's right this is this is real and uh
that's a real thing
so um delony dr dolony john talks about
that all the time that um you are not
your identity is not the worst thing
that ever happened to you correct
that is not who you are
you're not a
product of a negative
thing that happened
i'm not a product of being stupid and
being bankrupt by the time i was 28.
it's just a thing that happened
uh did it did it change me yeah did it
change the direction of my life you bet
but i'm not a product of it i'm not
dave ramsey and i filed bankruptcy
that's not that's not my identity it is
a thing in the rearview mirror nowadays
30 years in the rearview mirror
um more than 30 years
and so but but um
you know it's still there
there's still a thing there it's still
there but it's not defining the future i
love your story and i don't want the
audience to miss that you know dave's
obviously wildly successful now but it's
largely because of the failure you know
successful men and women don't let
failures define them they learn through
those failures they that
when you talk about that story when
everything's crashing down on you and
the shower's so hot you can barely stand
it i mean here you sit decades later
because you decided to learn from that
and move forward i'll be honest for
about six months all it is around one
well sure
and i blamed everybody else i blamed the
president i was just natural i was the
guy we're talking about not being you
know and then a buddy of mine goes you
know you have a whole bunch of lemons
you probably ought to make some lemonade
there you go
in other words i'm tired of you whining
you need to go do something with all
this and get up off your your whiny butt
yeah and uh he called me out and you
know that was that i remember where i
was sitting in that lunch with him
and uh that wasn't the only thing that
did it but i had had i just tried
whining long enough and it wasn't
working so i needed to try something
else well and you're an example that our
failures can refine us shape us the fire
the pounding you know i love watching
the old blacksmith when they take this
inanimate iron object and they stick it
in the heat and it gets piping hot and
it's red and they put it on the anvil
and beat the stuffing out of it all to
turn it into something extremely
valuable and so you've not lost your
value no that's what we're saying being
reshaped yeah and uh it but the the
hammer hurts oh and the fires and the
fire yeah and the fires getting there's
no fun it's real it's you know having a
testimony is a wonderful thing getting
one's a pain in the butt
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting for the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show where he talks about
getting the job that you love making the
money that you should
make and uh all things jobs and career
and you got questions about that jump in
he's here to help and we're gonna talk
about your life and your money it's what
we always do the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
dan is in scranton pennsylvania hi dan
welcome to the ramsey show
hello dave and crew thank you for taking
my call appreciated
so here's my situation i'm 61 years old
i'm going to be 62 in january i'll be
retiring from corporate america i'm
married 42 years i purchased the home in
pennsylvania this past april while my
new york home was up for sale and for
that pennsylvania home i got a 30-year
variable rate mortgage for 495 000
and it's currently fixed at 2.8 for the
next 10 years
with a payment of 2700 a month
i sold my new york home shortly after i
closed on the pa home so my question is
should i take the 500 000 from the sale
of my new york home and pay off the
pennsylvania mortgage or
should i invest that 500 000 in a
managed fidelity vanguard or some other
index fund and use that interest on the
500k to pay off the pa home at least for
the next 10 years and then reassess the
situation because i have no debt other
than that pa mortgage
my wife and i should be bringing home
about 11 000 a month when we retire as i
had a pension and i got 1.1 million in
my 401k which is mostly sending in cash
money market now wow what should i do
why is it in cash in money markets
um
well you know i've had invested in index
funds for two 25 years and i've done
well and they're on sale right now
i'm nervous with the i mean had i had
that in there where my mark is losing 20
this year so that's what scared me
i i dabbled back in about a month ago i
put the 300 000 into the market again
split it in index funds small medium
large uh cap index funds
33 and a third so
i i don't know i think the market's on
hey i'm your age and i think the
market's on sale i haven't taken any out
and i'm putting money in i think it's a
good buy right now
so you can do what you want to do but i
wouldn't have a million one sitting on
the sidelines making no money that'd
drive me nuts
um now what about the mortgage i pay it
off tomorrow
and not use the interest on that you've
asked this question suggesting the
answer six times um and so you really
don't want to pay off the mortgage you
really want to invest it but let me tell
you why i'm telling you to pay it off
okay in our study of ten thousand
millionaires that are sitting about
where you're sitting
the vast majority of them were between
one and three million dollar net worth
which is exactly where you're sitting
uh we found we did not find any of them
that said not one not a single one that
said the way i became a millionaire was
borrowing on my home to invest in the
stock market
none of them said that and effectively
that is your question isn't it
yeah should i borrow on my home at 2.8
percent and invest in index funds oh
wait i've got a million one on the
sidelines because i'm scared of the
market and i don't think it's going to
do that well you're talking out of both
sides of your mouth
you answered my question
[Laughter]
no you're hey dan listen here's the
thing
uh if i were in your shoes and i and i
am in the sense that we're about the
same age
i would be 100 debt free and i'd get
back in the market
uh with the other money and you're going
to have a great life the sense of peace
that you have when you have zero debt
is not definable with mathematics
and you've worked your butt off
and you have done a great job
of building a high quality retirement
dude you're a stud
you have killed this
and i'm well i've used your principles
i've been putting 13 of my salary away
for 28 years and you're and you're a
baby steps millionaire an everyday
millionaire you know you nobody gave you
any money you're the guy that got up
left the cave killed something and
dragged it home you showed up at work
when you didn't feel like it got stuff
done you got grit
you're that guy that's how you got where
you are i know that about you because i
can tell i can see it in the numbers
you don't get where you are being a
melting snowflake okay
you get where you are grinding
and and showing up and being a man of
honor and a man of duty and that that's
who you are am i wrong
that's what i did yeah and so and it
wasn't it wasn't fancy
and it wasn't sexy and all your
get-rich-quick friends thought you were
slow
but you weren't slow you kicked all
them's butt because here you sit with it
probably about a two million dollar net
worth give or take and and
and you did it man so i i want you to
enjoy
this season where you've lived like no
one else you paid a price now you get to
live and give like no one else and not
having a mortgage while you're on
vacation somewhere around the world with
your wife enjoying your 42 years of
marriage uh
it's it's a different thing man and i
want that for you i want that sense of
peace that sense of power
um we don't need to arbitrage your home
we don't need to leverage your home for
you to win you won
you already won yeah and i love the
advice that you give because i just walk
through that scenario
and he's got a house that's right at uh
he didn't tell us he told us what the
mortgage is it's probably worth more
than the 495 way more than that and so
now all of a sudden
with having no debt you have this asset
that's extremely valuable if you need to
liquidate it's there not to mention he's
invested you know and he's done so much
it isn't no he's not going to need it
but that's the whole idea is not carry
the debt at all this idea of well i'm
going to
pay my mortgage off with the interest
what's the temptation to follow though
you're going to have 20 000 he's got 11
000 already coming in when he puts that
million one to work and creates another
10 15 000 bucks a month yeah he's gonna
have 20 25 000 a month to live on and
have no payments
this sounds like a good life to me
i like your life
yeah it sounds like the american dream
dude i'm proud of you i'm proud of you
man he's
he's who we're trying to get people to
be 100 he's the poster child yeah yeah
well neither one of us are children
anymore but yeah
it's a post or something it's a metaphor
we're poster something's can but we're
not sure which you guys are young still
i think you got to get to 80 85 before
you can call yourself old in today's
world well just the older i get the
older my grandpa when he was 80. he kept
talking about this guy down the street
he said that old man
and i'm like grandpa you're 80. he goes
yeah but he's older than me he's a old
man so that's true no matter how old you
get somebody older
hopefully well at some point you run out
of candidates though
listen that guy dan dan you're a stud
man yeah i'm so proud of you and i would
just enjoy this and
uh don't overthink it
you didn't get here by overthinking it
you got here by executing
steady
rhythm
you stuck with it the grit that's how
you got here just keep doing that
not by trying to get fancy
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five
two two five guys we really value the
input from people who watch and listen
to the ramsey show it helps us know
what's important to you what you like
and the things that we want to change
and can change based on your input we
will
and uh we we love hearing from you we're
doing a survey right now it only takes a
few minutes obviously it doesn't cost
anything and those that take it will be
in a drawing for a 500 visa gift card
that obviously could be used for
anything that's a pretty nice gift so
go take the survey and you might be the
winner of that ramsey solutions.com
survey you can answer the questions on
your phone really quick won't take but a
minute ramsey solutions dot com
slash
survey
kyle is with us in montgomery alabama
hey kyle welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey ken thanks for taking my
call today sure what's up
well my wife and i found the baby steps
about four years ago and we were
fortunate enough to start on baby step
three uh since then we've taught fpu two
times
but we we are still hesitant to
cut up the credit cards and close the
accounts
we have that
fear of fraudulent debit card
purchases and i've heard you talk about
it before in the past about the
protections between debit and credit
cards yeah plan please own
my own research uh following hearing
those episodes i have uh looked into it
and found anecdotal evidence that people
suffer when their
debit cards get misused and then the
banks take a while or they may try to
refuse the refunds
by those
fraudulent charges do you have any
input or any other protections out there
that you would suggest to help prevent
those to help us get over that fear and
stop using credit cards yeah
um
first i would tell you that if you don't
get over the fear you should not lead
financial peace university
because it's you're telling you know
we're telling people to quit using
credit cards and you leading the class
are still using them as hypocritical
so that's not good for you it's not good
for the people in the class
so if you can't get if you can't deal
with this issue i understand i'm gonna
be mad at you but it's inconsistent for
when the cornerstone of the class is to
get rid of all debt
so that you can become wealthy so let's
set that on the table first secondly
absolutely
now secondly i carry
debit cards
um
and i have used them
literally all over the world i don't own
a single credit card
and i have had fraudulent transactions
i've had lots of scares lots of
shutdowns
lots of reverse charges
i have never had a bank
uh hold money on me
and i'm i'm probably my point is i'm
probably more exposed to fraud than the
average person because i travel so much
and i do so many different kinds of
transactions and we run all of ramsey
solutions a 300 million dollar company
with debit cards the company doesn't
have any credit cards
and so you know i've got like several
hundred people that work on the team
that carry a ramsey
debit card so we've got massive
exposure to what you're talking about
and our practical experience is it is so
rare
that something takes more than 24 or 48
hours to get refunded that it's uh you
know it's there now if you're buying
for
an amount of money
that if that amount of money doesn't get
returned to you
in 48 hours destroys your life
that says you shouldn't be buying
something like that
mathematically
and so
there's another level of lack of wisdom
that's involved in some of those stories
that you find in the
deep dark recesses of the internet uh in
your uh research that you've done but
the the practical fact is
we see so little
misbehavior by banks or stress put on
people by this that it that the offset
of now we'll tell you this the people
that use credit cards and pay them off
every month
78 percent don't
pay them off every month so someone's
lying
about paying them off every month
because when you talk to people they all
say they pay them off every month and
nobody does
and so you know the number of people
that fall into the trap of
getting screwed over by the use of
credit cards versus fall into the trap
of having their life considerably offset
by a delayed refund in the rare event of
a fraudulent transaction that actually
does
cost you money and how long does it take
to get back in your account is uh
you know the the numbers don't even i
mean it's a bazillion times more on
credit cards the lives are destroyed and
messed up than they are by somebody not
getting a fraud refund on a debit card
and so the trade-off is not even close
uh yeah there is there is a reality that
that can happen and it does happen on on
occasion but it is not a frequent thing
i'm giving you a set example that that i
literally have hundreds
of debit cards
yeah i i think the data will show you
kyle and i think you've done enough
research to know that the numbers would
tell you that it's an irritation this
fear that you have not a devastation and
there's two things you can do you ask
what could you do if you don't have
identity theft of zander insurance stacy
and i have that everybody at ramsey
solutions does identity theft protection
is going to help you there and protect
you and then i will tell you i'm not
going to endorse any bank but our
personal bank
they're so good with their security that
sometimes the state and i are out of
state and we forget to tell them we're
going something we just go to dinner and
it'll hit send me a text
your card was just charged your debit
card was charged at this restaurant are
you there are you in kaaba is it you yes
i am as a matter of fact it happened and
so um i think you've created a boogeyman
that really doesn't exist lurking around
every corner does it happen yes is it is
it devastating
number of times the number of times that
it is an actual
serious financial problem to a family
versus the number of times a credit card
is an actual serious financial problem
credit card is one tenth of one percent
these no they don't even they don't even
line up they're not even close they're
not in the same stratosphere of the
damage one does versus the damage
another does yeah not even close and so
the trade-off is just not worth it on
this one issue because debit cards have
a 100
fraud protection that's correct if it is
fraud the bank has to refund it that is
visas policy it is mastercard's policy
it is in there it's a zero liability
policy you can read it in their own
stuff and so the people who say cr and
he's not saying this but the people that
say well credit cards have fraud
protection debit cards don't that's not
true that's just not true he's not
saying that by the way but um to his
credit but the uh
but but
so for those of you out there your debit
card has the exact same fraud protection
your credit card has what he's referring
to is if you
uh went online and bought something with
your debit card and it was uh uh no
there's someone
someone stole your identity and used
your account or they picked up your card
number off a false reader or something
on a one of these rip off atm machine
things and they take your card and they
go buy something with it and it shows up
in your account
and it's 200 bucks
the it does 200 does come out of your
account
out of your checking account
and then you report the fraud and the
bank has to put it back
and the number of times that that causes
disaster on a family is almost zero
because a banks put it back really
really fast and b you shouldn't be using
any financial transaction that if it
goes sideways destroys your life that's
correct
period now i'll tell you what does
happen and then people use this
to whine about this as a justification
rationalization for using their credit
cards and this is not kyle but i hear it
all the time for people that are man
keep my credit card and we keep one
opening said because when i travel they
put a hold so when you check into a
hotel all right the one we were staying
in the other night i didn't use my car
because we were doing a corporate thing
we're out there and uh this account was
set up with omni but uh if i go check
into an omni or uh whatever by myself
with sharon and me they'll put a hold
on your account for the amount
so 400 bucks a night 300 bucks a night
200 whatever it is right they're gonna
put a hold on that and it might be a day
or two before it comes off but listen if
you can't afford a two or three or four
hundred dollar hold on your account
then you can't afford to stay in that
hotel you should be at home working
that's you know these are the things you
need to think about and but they're like
well they took that two hundred dollars
down i could it took three days it took
eight days for the omni took the hold
off of it but that sometimes does happen
yeah but you don't need to be doing
stuff that you can't afford
that that's the other thing so
yeah it's up to you kyle you get to
decide man but the trade-off for me is
obvious it's a minor irritation versus
the damage that credit cards have done
to american families for decades this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today as we
talk to you about your careers your jobs
your life and your money
jump in if you want to talk the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five christopher is with us
he is in saint cloud minnesota hi
christopher how are you
i'm doing pretty good say um i'll just
start with my question first um
considering my situation should i buy a
house now with that being said my
current situation i'm currently a nurse
new nurse that i graduated with my
associate's degree this past spring but
i'm also a student pushing my r in the
bsn and i'm also a landlord um and so
i'm kind of like you know with all these
things at play you know working
part-time
and in my situation should i buy a house
and i know that's not a whole ton of
information but that's okay i got you so
so you're you're how old
i'm 22. and you make how much money
uh gross right now being part-time it's
about 36 100.
okay
so you're finishing up school right now
correct yep i'm doing the rn the bs
sense i'm currently a registered nurse
but it's a wonderful career path
um now i would concentrate on that i
don't want you to get
distracted i want you to finish school
sure so do that how are you a landlord
well i bought a house with my brother in
2018 and we've rented it out ever since
and it's all paid for
so you were 18 years old
correct
we bought it for well a little
background i used to do construction
before nursing and so we bought a house
that was like 31 000 fixed it up and
then rented it out and then
what would it sell for
probably right now 110 in being in that
location
okay
if you didn't own it would you buy it
right now
um
no probably not won't y'all sell it
uh because we're renting it right now i
guess
it's a single family
yeah single family home so when's the
lease
up uh it would be i think in december if
i remember correctly okay
i would consider putting that house on
the market after the first year and
getting rid of it here's the thing i
don't think that house
although it was a neat experiment for
you and experience to do that at 18
years old i don't think that house is
the secret sauce to your future nor is
home ownership at 22 the secret sauce to
your future i think the secret sauce to
your future is you
finishing this
nursing path that you are on you are
going to have tremendous opportunity to
make a lot of money and uh stay steadily
employed the rest of your life as long
as you want to be a nurse i mean this is
an incredible feel there's such a
shortage and ken the upside's really
strong there's a lot of upside for you
uh as a nurse even if you want to go
beyond that after a while and i would
agree with dave here the houses are
still going to be there you're 22
you've got this investment property that
you could absolutely sell take your
portion of the profit and that becomes a
part of your down payment but i wouldn't
be in any kind of rush i'd get through
school let's get in nursing let's get
settled let's get our sights on where we
want to go within nursing what that
mountain top looks like
the houses will be there sometimes
christopher people
miss achieving a major goal in their
life not because the goal was hard but
because they got distracted and added
too many other things on their plate
and that and home ownership and
landlording and all that other crap
while you're just trying to get through
school i'm trying to clean up your plate
and just say focus on what really
matters what the real goal is and these
other things could just be devilish
distractions
evan is with us in albany new york hi
evan how are you
good guys how you doing better than we
deserve sir how can we help
yeah so um
me and my dad well he owns a business
i've been i've been only working here
for two years now
but he's he's been relapsing over the
past year relapsing
relapsing sorry and what why i mean
in a in a drinking problem way okay so
he's an alcoholic
and he's back in the bottle we're trying
to run the business
yep wow i'm sorry
what's the business
say again sir what is the business
yeah it's a um pest control business
pest control and how old are you
i'm 20. and how many employees does he
have
uh almost 40.
and uh you're 20. how long has your dad
been drinking
um on and off for the past
15 20 years your whole life
yeah
and you've been running around trying to
clean up his messes your whole life
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
that's hard
so what's your question evan
i'm just
well the bottom line is pretty much like
how do i get him back to work he's kind
of bedridden right now um yeah
um
your mom gone
um divorce divorce yeah no kidding
not shocking okay
um has he put you in a leadership
position or are you just one of the
employees who happens to be his son what
kind of responsibility do you have for
the business
um i i do have some responsibility there
i'm one of the managers of a member of
the budget and advertising and billing
we have like five other managers who
thank god i know what they're doing and
they're very good okay so the business
is doing well despite his absence
let me tell you
let's just stop let's just stop okay the
um
the advice i'm going to give you is
going to be very hard to hear are you
ready to hear it
yep okay
um
there's a whole syndrome
around adult children of alcoholics
you can look it up and start reading
about the symptoms of
an adult child that grew up in an
alcoholic home
and
one of the things that
we see folks that grow up like you've
grown up
is you you've seen so much pain and
there's so much disaster
in the wake of all the alcoholism that
you you feel like your job is always to
clean up the messes
and that's a standard reaction to this
situation
um
if you were
my little brother if you were my nephew
if if if you and i could sit down
together and a cup of coffee i could put
my arm around you and give you a hug i
would right now and i would tell you
that it's time for you to stop saving
your father
he's gonna have to do that himself you
can do that as a loving son from a
distance
but if i were you i would go get a job
somewhere else and build a life
somewhere else
and from a position of strength
emotionally and spiritually begin to do
some healing from what all you've been
through
and from that position of strength maybe
you can give your dad a little bit of
aid
with his alcoholism but it is not your
job evan at 20 years old to save your
dad from the mess that he has made for
the last 15 years and that includes his
screwed up business life
you don't have that it's not your job i
want to set you free from that
assignment it is not your assignment run
please run for your sake
you know i i don't know if you'll do
that or not i don't know if you can hear
me say this or not
but you need to be free of this
and it doesn't mean you never speak to
your dad again it doesn't mean you're
mean to your dad it doesn't mean you're
unkind to him or that you yell at him
because he's destroyed everything with
his drinking i'm not telling you to do
any of that i'm just saying you have to
have some separation and go get some
healing on your own because dude what
you have lived through as a child has is
wounding
it's and you know and the
one of the biggest symptoms is that
adult children of alcoholics have to
have everything perfect
they have to have everything perfect
because their job was to keep up
appearances
because dad's laying in bed drunk and so
my job is to go down and run the
businesses if he's not
and it's it's a form of denial and it
comes out specifically in this and i'm
not a psychologist dr john delonay you
might want to talk to him
uh i'll put you on whole kelly i'll set
up time to talk to him on the air if you
want he'll tell you the same thing i'm
telling you though you've got to have
some separation from this situation in
order to be of assistance to your dad
and it's not your job young man
to fix all this
be free
it's not your job to fix this
you didn't break it it is not your duty
to fix it
and you're not a bad son
by walking away from this the best thing
you can do for you and for your dad is
to walk away from this
and then you can give him aid as a
loving son from a little more distance
in a position of healing
please
go work somewhere else
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today
[Music]
first peter 1 13 therefore prepare your
minds for action keep sober in spirit
fix your hope completely on the grace to
be brought to you at the revelation of
jesus christ
mark smith said if you fail to prepare
you're prepared to fail
that's a name i haven't heard in a while
yeah mark spitz
olympic swimmer is that right big time
okay well that was challenging multiple
multiple multiple gold medals before
there was michael phelps yeah he was the
guy all right all right he was the guy
wow that's a long time ago though
uh open phones at eight eight two five
five two two
k is in raleigh north carolina hi kay
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks dave
i'm going along with the theme here
today i think of car
questions
we have gotten ourselves into quite a
bit of credit card debt over the past
year
and um i'm wondering
um we are doing the plan right now and
we're very gazelle intense and we have a
lot of stuff that we're selling
my husband's income is getting ready to
go up
in december and he's also getting ready
to get quite a few bonuses
um in the next couple of months
and i'm wondering if we could wait for
some of that stuff to happen and
continue to be
gazelle intense
before we think about
selling one of our cars
or if we should just do it now and
then you know whenever that extra money
comes in i guess it's just extra money
okay why are you selling the car
to pay off the credit card debt oh
actually
okay
so what what is the car the cars worth
what are they worth
we have a um
like a classic sports car that's paid
off that probably right now is worth
about thirty thousand dollars
um my car and then he drops that paid
off
um
he actually yes quite a bit i mean he
doesn't it's not a daily driver oh so
it's a third car it's a third car it's a
third car yeah okay so you have a thirty
thousand dollar third car and the second
car is what
what are you oh
what was it worth where it's it's worth
probably right now about 35 to 40 and
it's paid off okay and what's the next
one
the next car
is
we do have a loan on that for 30 000 and
it's probably worse right now about 40.
okay and so
it sounds like you have a hundred 110
000 worth of vehicles
yes and what is your household income
it's about
160
and by the end of the year it should be
about 200.
um well i mean the rule of thumb that we
use is to not have too much tied up in
things that are going down in value and
our definition of that is when you have
more than 50 percent of your household
income tied up in things with wheels and
motors
then you've got too much tied up and
things are going down in values makes it
mathematically hard to get ahead
you are you guys are car poor
for sure
now if you got 110 000 worth of cars or
a hundred thousand dollars worth of cars
you make 200 you're right on the bubble
on that okay so no i would not sell
those cars based on that formula
uh the other formula we look at is can
you be debt free except the house
if you keep all of these things in 24
months
so you have fifty thousand dollars in
credit card debt and you have
uh forty or thirty thousand dollars in
car debt that's eighty what other debt
do you have not counting your house
nothing okay so can you pay off 80 in 24
months yeah you probably can
so if you love if you love these cars i
would keep them but and but i also want
you guys to look at each other and go we
were right on the bubble on stupid and
we don't need to get up on this bubble
again
okay because you don't get rich buying
cars
no
and you guys have invested a large chunk
of your lives
in cars and so they're right on the
bubble and if you love all three of the
cars and you want to hold them you're
going to be in a position shortly to
have kept them and that makes sense
mathematically but you really have to
address
your addiction to automobiles
because you're gonna struggle if you
don't that that's the whole process
so
um hey but you're you're right there i
i'm with you i would probably keep them
and i'd probably pay them all off but
the only caveat is just go you know if
we hadn't had these big races we'd be
selling some stuff oh yeah and they're
still going to have to hustle yeah
they're going to have to get after this
you know i i like classic cars in this
situation i was very i was i was
surprised a little bit not at your
philosophy but i'd move one of those
cars if the classic car means a lot to
the guy i would downgrade in my everyday
driver to be able to pay off the classic
car that's me that i would want to fast
but i want to fast forward everything
yeah i don't want to struggle when i
can't make one transfer 80 000 bucks and
you got you know you got 24 months yeah
so you're gonna do beans and rice in
order to keep these cars is it really
worth it to me it's not what happens a
lot of times is when people get into
that they get about they get about six
months into it and they go screw it sell
the car that's right you're right they
end up at that conclusion and but you
know because right now in this
conversation we love these cars oh yeah
but once you start figuring out this is
killing me i'm having to live on nothing
i make 200 a year i'm living on nothing
these cars own me yeah and you'll dump
one of them then yeah i agree that's
what will happen but uh it doesn't
always happen but it can't it can it can
uh up next is james in knoxville hi
james welcome to the ramsey show how's
it going better than i deserve what's up
so i have a camper that i have been
going back and forth with
with my wife on um i feel like we should
sell the camper
i don't feel like it is a
a bill that we need to keep paying on
every month um how much do you owe on it
it's about 25 000 what will it sell for
man prices have gone up on everything i
think i could probably get 35 for it
okay and what's your household income
65 000.
sell the camper
that's what i feel like but trying to
convince my wife is a bit tough yeah
with what you're spending on this camper
you can stay in the freaking ritz
yeah yeah and they'll let you sleep in a
sleeping bag out on the balcony if you
want
it'll make you feel better i don't think
that's true and the other
the other thing too is you know you got
to pay for uh you know diesel fuel to
get where you're going you got to pay to
stay there i feel like it's stupid you
are you are paying rich money for
camping
but why does she love it why why do you
think if she hasn't articulated what do
you think is the reason she doesn't want
to sell it
well
we talked about it last night actually
uh she feels like
um you know our kids are young yeah and
if we sell this camper and we don't have
any other debt beside this camper and
our mortgage um so
you know if we get rid of this i think
she feels like she's missing out on uh
i don't know totally get it all right so
what's your monthly payment to the uh
camper right now
about 425. yeah cast another vision yeah
at 425 a month that's gonna be memory
after memory after memory but zero
stress i just think you got to replace
her feelings i understand what she's
feeling i think she's right doing stuff
with the kids would be really cool for
400 bucks a month you can do it with a
lot and just replace the camper with
another vision yeah where are we going
to go i mean go stay in some rustic
cabins go do some stuff that other
people own and you don't have to screw
with it and then sit in the backyard
going down in value
and um
and it's not it's the only big payment
you have and so um yeah you guys you
guys didn't buy a camper you bought a
dream of family time while the kids are
little and doing stuff so go live that
dream ken's right a different way
and uh that doesn't involve owning the
stupid thing
um
and i'm not against campers but honestly
a 25 000 camper when your household
income is 60 000 is out of control
that's just that's a lot of money
uh and so
i wouldn't do that i just i wouldn't do
it i mean i i you're better off to just
spend the money on hotels spend the
money on rustic cabins whatever you want
to call it whatever the adventure is but
go on different adventures
that are with a similar amount of money
being spent
and um
that that are accomplishing the goal
that she wants to accomplish i'm not
arguing with her goal i think her goal
is valid yes well she's a mama and they
they want to have some great memories
and you can do that and i think you
should yeah we've done a lot of stuff
with our kids as they were growing up
and it's that you know some of those
stories they still talk about them as
adults the stuff we did when they were
little and yeah you got to drag them
around and make them uncomfortable
that's part of the program yeah i think
you should get the whole family really
nice sleeping bags and try that rich
plan that dave's talking about i want to
see how that works out
come on kids we're going to the ritz
balcony
all right
all right smart alec ken coleman
james
ben zach and austin and kelly in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
you